to what you're saying in terms of
it's not always necessarily a choice
what i'm saying is
it's not as black and white as as was
saying that you've got to look at the
root issue i'm not saying it it
minimizes their accountability or
responsibility in the how they
contribute to themselves putting on
weight what i'm saying is that look at
the root issue there might be a lack of
adequate education i'm not even really
saying the emotional thing like don't
get me wrong i know where you're coming
from a bit and that's probably from
personal experience and that's why you
truly believe it might not be always the
case what i'm saying is that in life
there's always a root issue right
but the root the root issue could be
like a medication yeah but the root the
root issue could just be a lack of self
control and eating good foods
so so i'll give you an example for for
me right so i used to have this issue
where i would get like stupid hungry
like i would be so hungry i just had
like a bottomless pit and i felt like i
couldn't figure it out but what i
figured out was i wasn't eating
nutrient-dense foods